Jim was hanging out with the with
Jonathan Johnny bran muffins
the original bran muffin by the way it's
on big pocket it's not his pocket that's
big and yeah I guess this is a this is
how it went out there in Los Angeles
yeah boss that wasn't part of the video
this no that wasn't no because I saw you
studio and I saw you push did you see
him push Bob I've seen him push we don't
have to play it I've seen it but it's
not for you Oh somebody's joy I'm just
talking he's being humble let's not play
content on the radio it's like it's like
when a musician like doesn't want to
hear it like Thom Yorke from Radiohead
doesn't want to hear creep again but we
all like it
it's one of your greatest hits Jim is
like that with fart videos but I should
enjoy this cuz this is a newer and chip
yeah well let's see what happened when
you were hanging out with young Jonathan
yeah
[Laughter]
just for a sec what I love is Jim's
technique where you know like like one
of my favorite Norton things is your
fake conversation start you know what
you're doing he goes oh yeah no no
there's just this thing and then you
stop momentarily and then he doesn't
pick up a little bit let that flow
happen it's not gonna work it's not
gonna have his full potential you can't
trap it I love that Jonathan stuck his
head out the window like a golden
retriever we were in traffic and he'd
you can't even see what a violent jerk
of the wheel he did it looked like that
he drove like almost into oncoming
traffic to try to go around I don't I
don't know what he went to get momentum
he's trying he's trying to get the
airflow through the way I think he just
went into a panic and he was like maybe
if I beat this traffic the fart will go
away you have terrible farts yeah the
food you eat and when it goes into your
[ __ ] and whatever whatever old ship
[ __ ] you have like an old oil tanker
inside there it's just mixes with the
walls of your [ __ ] dumper putrid it's
very interesting because you have out
bad I bet certain Chinese people would
like dipping their food it's very
interesting cuz you're in great shape
you have a wonderful body but the inside
what I think Jim's got a wonderful body
wonderful I think so yeah well you look
good but there's something on the inside
in clothes out of clothes it really is a
hard show how to clothes
there's a decision to make yeah she go
back to Jonathan violently jerking the
wheel to try to drive away from a fart
in the car he's an adult I gotta go to
the restaurant next and we parked the
car and Jonathan parked a little askew I
had dropped a gasser in the car right
before we got out I figured I'd leave it
but I didn't plan on him parking so
poorly I saw it I kept encouraging him
to move that I couldn't believe he's
gonna get right back in and they were
like dude you gotta move it I do I
thought it would come back after lunch
and maybe they'd be a remnant yeah he
literally this is like 15 seconds after
I dropped it in the [ __ ] car
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]